t4 date update dot a that obtained and
YouTube Dodi my name is Mary Han good
evening and welcome to peel news
it's hammertime good evening welcome to
pornos Mary ham our first story comes
from T Fuu T for who is t fool you might
ask he's the guy that looks like the
fortnight guy huh what a coincidence
he's got 10 million subscribers on
YouTube he is the fortnight guy right
now
ninja excuse me it's all about t Fuu now
although maybe not for long ninja don't
worry
because t field is losing subscribers oh
my god what did T food duty food do
people do what did T fo do oh well T Fuu
is suing face faves which is the client
I don't know what it is I never know
it's a fake I think it's a client see
how he has set a little logo there that
means he's part of phase that means he's
super good game super bro and now he's
suing them that's crazy
ever since T foo has stopped uploading
or doing his streams in the report it
says that his contract would face is
one-sided but I think the main thing
that people are focused about here is
the 80% thing one of the world's top
professional eSports players this soon
his gaming organization for allegedly
restraining his business opportunities
and taking up to 88% hey he's got my
glasses
daddy 80% so apparently phase this clan
this management forty few has me taking
84 she also said that they've been
limiting sponsor deals obtained through
this team basically he can only do bonds
are shapes through phase I think that's
how I understand it and if you spoke a
few days prior about sort of not working
with companies and you should just be
independent if you are in the World Cup
or you think you're going to qualify do
not signed in org
unless it says in the contract
that they don't take any earnings from
tournaments and if you're in a contract
that says that you need to get a lawyer
and get out of that contract oh my god
that's what he's doing
TV you did say though that he was
getting all his prize earnings I keep
all my earnings yeah but why are other
people mad at T few then they makes
enough sense if they take 80% that's
really bad he also says that he was
reportedly pushed into living in one of
the group's LA homes alongside other
young Selim's nobody literally nobody
not a single soul t phew they forced me
to live in a mansion for free how could
they I mean he could have been
threatened or oh if you're not part of
the thing then to be fair I we don't
know what's going on and he gets even
weirder he also says that he was
encouraged to drink alcohol while
underage TV was 20 years old at this
time shut the [ __ ] up okay you're
drinking already people were very quick
to point this out even in his own videos
yo what the there's snow up here yo guys
I don't really drink but I am having
sounds what a drinker would say
according to the ni a a a 60% of the you
admit to drinking at least one by the
time they're 18 years old now I would
never absolutely never encourage
underage people to drink but it's also
you're full of bull whip crapper he also
said that he was continuously pressured
to perform stunts in his video like why
is are they bringing this up in a legal
dispute it really seems like grasping
for straws if you bring this up and face
bank one of the founders of faze
addresses as well [ __ ] sicko jump off
the [ __ ] you've been doing that far far
far before you met us and the first
thing you did when you came to LA the
very first thing you did was you brought
us all up to the reservoir and you
jumped off of the Hollywood reservoir if
anyone was pressuring anybody into doing
that it was you pressuring Tommy his
brother gwit into doing it
if you don't jump you got to jump with
one of us huh got him
apparently face banks and tea fewer
friends and he got very upset about this
lawsuit seeing it as a big betrayal and
I think that's why this whole story
really blew up so much and banks
addresses the whole 80 20 percent split
saying that absolutely 1000% untrue the
short answer is we have collected and
earned $60,000 from tfoo since we
originally started our relationship
which was about a year and a half ago
well that's obviously not 80 percent I
don't think that's 80% of what T foo
makes in a day so basically saying that
old faces done is collect sixty thousand
from him which has been through brand
deals and in those brand deals they
haven't taken eighty percent they've
taken twenty percent we should still in
the higher end but it's not that bad but
I think the important distinction here
is that on t fuse contract it says that
that they can take eighty percent it's
just the fact that they haven't done
that but contractually I understand why
he wants to get out of this contract it
sounds like a bogus contract if that's
the case plus the fact that he seems
like he's exclusive with phase X well as
well he's obviously missing out on other
deals there and the fact that any deal
he takes they will take 20% it's not
that great of a deal sure 20% it's not
terrible but it's not great either
ajan this kid has made a gross amount of
money and we've collected a grand total
of $60,000 from him it is a good point
though what is he complaining if they're
not taking any money from him sounds
like a pretty good deal a lot of people
point out that by looking at the stats
of when T few joined this client to how
that blew up his career here on April
30th he joined phase and you can see
same month is when it really started
skyrocketing now obviously just looking
at a stat and saying okay well he joined
here so therefore all his successes
thanks to face but banks even brought up
a lot of example in his video of how
much they've done for this kid you're
the captain I trust your judgment
I trust your call I want you to have the
roster that you want but with that being
said please play with my homie T foo
he's really [ __ ] good just scream
with him give him a chance and cloaks
response to that was something along the
lines of I know who he is we're not
interested Turner knows how to get kills
but he's not good at building we have
this person this person this person this
person in mind he don't want to play
with T foo again I pushed him yo just
play with him
just please scrim with him just give me
that much that's all I asked and he did
the rest is simply history they played
together and they crushed it they won
scream after scream and they were stoked
everyone was like this is really where T
foo started to really make his name
banks lists a lot of reasons why what he
did to help T few flustered man like
have this kid's name tattooed on my
[ __ ] leg like imagine how dumb I feel
right now
so in The Hollywood Reporter we get some
word from T food more about his
perspective on the whole thing and what
they say is that he's only gets to keep
20% of the revenue from it from any
branded videos it seems so far that
that's false missing out on
opportunities okay I understand and
apparently he attempted to terminate the
agreement claiming that faze clan
breached their deal but they rejected
his decision and he's also seeking
punitive damages against face Kline
apparently faze clan offered a
seven-figure bonus and taking 0% but
they've been rejected I think the
emphasis here is on how they say
collected right and we've collected a
grand total of $60,000 from him we only
collect them 60,000 that might mean that
they feel like they at any point
I mean contractually at any point that
can say hey actually according to this
deal that we have you're signed for 8020
we can take that money contractually
they have every right to do that but it
seems like they had more of a trust
relationship in terms of me
renegotiating a contract when you're
already locked in it's not a good place
to negotiate so I always understand
despite being offered a big deal why you
would cut this contract I think we're
the reason why a lot of people are upset
is for all those dumb reasons that they
added along with this like the stunts
and alcohol and also it seems from what
we can tell the betrayal of a friendship
but then again we don't really know too
so I don't know T fuse law firm are
sending a message the time is now for
content creator gamers and streamers to
stop being taken advantage up through
oppressive unfair illegal agreements yah
I mean the thing is I agree with this
but it's all this is all done in the
completely wrong reasons most networks
that exist right now most management
through YouTube have completely fallen
apart because YouTube finally made it so
you don't have to depend on them when I
started I'm still salty about this
because when I started off there on
YouTube I had no choice but to sign up
with networks that were so lucrative
they would give you actual illegal
contracts and they would take fifty
percent of your revenue because you it
was that or nothing
YouTube would not monetize specific
creators especially gamers so he created
this terrible relationship when networks
where they essentially just took your
money and you had no leverage to go
against it it was that or nothing if
there's one message from all this is
don't sign anything unless you know
where you getting yours hundred percent
into too many people just read a
contract with their parents and they
sign aremy like oh we think we
understand get a lawyer to look after it
I don't care how small of a youtuber you
are don't sign anything unless you're
100% sure that you know what you're
getting into
there's too many people still make this
mistake don't do it don't do it it's
harder to get out of a contract than it
is to get in one I've dealt with the
similar situations I understand TPU in a
sense but it also feels very fishy in
the whole situation but it remains to
see what he has to say we don't know
what's been happening behind closed
doors could be more juice little more
tea perhaps
what's up it's me am from the future tea
few has them now posted a response so
obviously we have to get through it
let's watch yo what is up guys I'm gonna
keep this via really short all the stuff
about the gambling the stunts the
drinking I told my lawyer I did not want
that in there and he will do exactly
just that he will take it out so that is
it no worries no worries guys if he
didn't want that in
I shouldn't have been in there okay your
lawyer represents you tea whew hey
there's no way he put that in there
without your consent
everyone have said anybody I never want
to bring that stuff in I never wanted to
get anybody to get emotional because
this isn't about that this is about me
in this contract this contract that I
signed when I didn't know any better I'm
an idiot I should have never signed it
in the first place
what is in this contract is so bizarre I
wish you guys could see this thing
because I can't even fathom it yeah what
is in this contract is insane and that's
not even the worst parts and what I'm
trying to do here is just serve justice
to the eSports community the eSports
industry these kids are getting ripped
off they're getting taken advantage of
and I'm the first person to stand up and
say this is not right this is not cool
and if only you guys could see what is
in this contract release the contract
everybody
hashtag release contract release it
hashtag relieves the contract is out
everyone this response in my opinion not
good okay it's sort of acts as if in
good favor that we have to take his word
for that the contract is so bad when
people are already on the fence now I
personally don't doubt that it is bad
I'm just saying if I had people
breathing down my neck
I wouldn't go trust me guys it's really
bad and now banks is gonna release an
hour video responding to this if I was
teef you I would say I know all that I
know all the points about drinking and
about doing the Sun it was stupid and I
should never have brought it up but I
should be a testimony to just how
desperate I am to get out of this
contract even though face hasn't taken
collected as they say any money from me
now there's nothing legally in this
contract to stop them from doing so all
this hard work and effort that I spent
over the past couple years I don't know
how long he's been famous it could just
be completely stripped away because of
this it's not right and yes I was an
idiot for signing this but this type of
good deals should not exist to begin
with and they will continue to happen
unless unless someone there's something
about him I mean he did kind of
formulate it in that sense
I never meant to make this a personal I
never meant this to hurt anyone's
feelings
but my livelihood is at stake here and I
need to fight for it I'm sorry to banks
for hurting his feelings he's like a
brother to me and I'm appreciative of
everything he's done but I need to ask
for one thing and that is for them to
release me from this contract if they
actually care about me the way they say
I think that's the least I can do it's
not right and it's not fair and I'm
willing to drop everything if that just
goes through cuz that's his goal right
he just want to be out of the contract I
would propose some sort of in-between
settlement the thing is this lawsuit is
bigger than just a dispute between
releasing the contract okay the labor
commission has been notified in
California and they are now forced to
respond to this I don't know exactly how
it works if they will have to launch
some sort of investigation but they're
basically saying that talent agencies
are supposed to be licensed and
regulated by the labor commission to
protect young talent from being suckered
into contracts like this they say that
eSport teams have been operating as
unread regulated talent agencies for
years a direct violation of the talent
agency Act most of these confiscated
streamers are very young and are often
unsophisticated on the season and
trusting as a result these young con the
Creator streamers are susceptible to
being taken advantage of and exploited
often by those who are supposed to be
looking out for their best interests
unfortunately this has become an
industry standard they are fighting to
change the way these eSport groups are
made or are functioning if the labor
commission is forced to respond then
there could be major changes happening
here this is bigger than just the
contract people were even speculating
that face might have to shut down
because of this that's why if they could
just come to some sort of conclusion
I'll drop my charges you drop my your
contract I don't know like apparently t
fuse lawyers some sort of Big Shot he's
recognized a silenced California super
lawyer for 12 years
if this gets dirty right if this gets
ugly teef you could be completely
screwed and the same way with face that
the stakes are very very high here all
right
sit for next more ham next ham in an old
story that basically Tati may not have
monetize her video but she's sure
monetized mine
patty apparently claimed Ethan from a
tree's video this is so sad
Tati also gave out a copyright strike to
another que channel that criticized her
and it was all looking very very fishy
luckily she's removed the claims and
apologized and it seems that they were
made an error but why are people doing
this automated claims to begin with stop
your stop apparently she has people
using footage of her without permission
and that's why she activated this system
the YouTube system is already so goddamn
broken and just don't use it don't use
auto claims never use it also to free
star bonded to the James Charles drama
and it seemed like that was the end of
the drama it's the dumbest video I've
probably seen in a very very long time
just basically goes oh I've been in a
dork please I accused James Charles are
being a sexual predator with no evidence
but you know I'm better than that so I'm
not gonna address any of the evidence
for it because I'm better than that and
now I'm just like dark place we're all
in a dark place and I was in a very dark
place where is his place they're going
to the range but it seemed at least that
it's finally solidified the end of the
Totti James and Geoffrey drama saga
thank God mixed news Holly responds
that's right what keemstar called the
side hoe of the whole pro Jarrod
cheating situation finally came out and
made a response she made a very long
threat on Twitter she called out pro
Jarrod for making bad decisions about
exchanging nudes with fans she says that
she she has seen relevant receipts which
prove that pro Jarrod confirmed the
consent in ages of those individuals he
interacted with for those who don't know
she also says that people that posted
his nudes without consent it's called
revenge porn and is a felony in 48
states as foolish as I think it is to
exchange nudes with fans
and how bizarre that is and how much I
have disdained for that sort of thing
leaking these nudes is kind of up the
leg
it's interesting how no one brings up
that ethical aspect of it she calls out
Heidi Pro Jared's ex-wife for being
abusive and having an abusive
relationship and she posted tweet
screenshots of that and sort of
threatening how embarrassing and how bad
it would be for you Pro Jared if this
all came out to light what she's
referring to exactly I don't know also
posting text messages about how she lied
about not being poly and approving of
the nudes now I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but seeing all these texts
and reading through this thread Heidi
seems to me like a very aggressive
resentful and mean-spirited person if
she got cheated on I do feel for her but
it doesn't seem like it was the case I
love how Holly posts like a lot of
evidence and improves in the text and
everyone's just like uh I think we need
more proof to see like if these are real
texts
no one asked that variety everyone was
completely on board from the beginning
oh she said he cheated oh well he must
have done it then now she's defending
herself and everyone's like all this
sudden hmm maybe it's fake I find it
very very interesting it's like
everyone's already made up their mind
about this whole situation I think
though however I still stand by what my
take on it is that probably everyone
involved is responsible in more in one
way or another
it remains to see Pro Jared's response I
would not be surprised if Pro Jared
makes a video showing evidence of what
has happened and what is more or less
what went down
even if Heidi was cheating on and was
treated poorly I don't think this public
persecution was it was okay the things
that she said about Holly
this is mean and disgusting I'm curious
to see what's gonna happen here cuz I
don't think it's over yet also I feel
like I should mention I've
met Holly twice obviously I don't you
can never know truly about anyone I just
don't see her doing anything bad I can't
picture it
yes I've only met her twice extremely
briefly I just don't I don't see it I
just don't see it next news finally this
has been all over my reddit about a
copyright claim it's the top voted thing
on my reddit it says all these 3,000
videos got claimed even though he had
the music license to him yeah I've had a
bit of a strange situation to come on my
youtube channel
this guy had as an outro or intro this
song that he do to the artists who made
it got license for using so he had every
right according to this artist to use
his song then all the sudden this this
company started claiming every single
one of his videos
she's obviously terrifying I can't
imagine that happening to me and he he
just says well I had the right to use
these I'm gonna have to go through every
single one of these the whole system is
just completely broken and I agree
that's ridiculous now the unfortunate
event of this is that even though he had
permission some samples in that song
that artist I gave him permission didn't
have permission to use so ridiculous but
that's the reality of copyright laws
YouTube I know I I did see that YouTube
was in touch with this guy hopefully
they'll get it sorted out if it does and
I'll be sure to report on it most likely
what YouTube can do is edit these videos
and edit out the outro and then resubmit
a claim and hopefully they'll get
released that's at least what I think is
the easiest way to solve it it's just
it's fun stuff that you have to deal
with when you're a youtuber YouTube it's
the best thank you for watching another
episode of peer news it's been my
pleasure to be your host today Papa
Gloria unfortunately I know there's a
petition to get Papa Gloria back but
once you're out you're out okay
I'm ham and I'm done with the new Spike
what you never played to purr simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay
I'll cut you a deal the game is
available for free and that's a great
price
[Music]